I know you're single and you're dating
and you're out there and yet and we've
we've talked about your dating life not
going well it's terrible why is it
terrible worst men are so poorly behaved
at all times no I will speak for Andy
and myself we are not poorly behaved at
all times there's a lot of gentlemen out
there first of all I'm not I just said
that I'm not out there so I don't know
all right I'll find you a man what no
first of all I know that you are very
particular that's where I get
intimidated about trying to pick someone
for you
because you told me once that you keep
notes on all the people you've dated yes
you raped them and you keep notes on
them what's in these notes so I just go
through the date did I have fun was he
creative was he boring do you have a big
was it cards was it wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute it sounds like you
have you mentioned it right and then
when you get to penis there's all these
subcategories alike so you got to rate
them you know so so I have a memory of
it so I can return back to the Google
Doc and be like ah Tim
Emilie's curved to the left but in any
good I hope I was thinking I think I
know Tim Tim goes to my gym
Wow ok do they know that you're writing
all this down aren't we at the moment
way insane no you're not they're going
like hold on hold on
imagine I'm just like riding him I'm
like wait it's ok ok come on
[Applause]
trying to run a respectable show Andy
and I are trying to get this thing on
Nickelodeon and that every time we get
this close and then you come on your
ride and Tim with his curve can I don't
know that must be very intimidating did
you ever think it's intimidating from
then maybe you intimidate them I know
I'm just throwing out ideas for why
you're a very lovely person I don't know
why you'd be having all this difficult I
don't know either they don't know about
the Google Doc so it's well they do now
other words out that they're gonna get a
rating but like wouldn't that be fun to
go out with someone and be like she's
gonna write about this later
no no forget real specific about the
penis I mean I'm fine with it
[Applause]
are you fine with it
oh my soul just left my box